[Music]
it's such a such a well-made br man i
feel really bad for people that just
can't
break out and enjoy it you know what i
mean
i mean hey if you're addicted to
fortnite and you're rocking it it's
oh my god but uh damn
th this has got to be one of the best
games i've ever played
i mean that you're not jerking off in
the open shots
one more one
control uh control
yep
half the prize pool goes to the players
okay
because i don't know if that i don't
know that graphic showed that but um the
other half goes to charity
nick it's captain price
quite the little movement you've been
growing the mfam
is it a bunch of certified mad men led
by the original bad man himself
it's big things man big big things we're
partnered up with activision now
nick mercs is twitch's current
controller god
i'm a [ __ ] god i'm a god come on man
come on man come on the dude is an
og when it comes to console esports and
he even competed professionally in gears
of war and halo before turning into a
streaming
titan he even competed against ninja
back in the day
and those two had a pretty intense
rivalry but you almost you almost well
you ran up to me in freaking like
meadowland
that was all i i was trying to throw
down
if you punched me i i would have ran in
2010
nick mercs moved from competitor to
entertainer and started his journey into
content creation
to open windows
[ __ ] at first he just streamed for fun
since streamers weren't making anything
close to what they're making now
i loved gaming i always always wanted to
do it but you know back when i started
nobody really knew that this was going
to turn into this so we were all just
kind of winging it
kind of like we are today man i mean
it's pretty crazy what gaming's turned
into but uh
like when i started streaming there was
no really no real way to make any money
uh we were just kind of doing it for fun
through first-person shooters like call
of duty nick merc steadily grew a loyal
fan base which he affectionately
nicknamed mfam and with the release of
fortnite his channel
exploded
he became one of twitch's premier
fortnight streamers even though he used
a controller
which a lot of people considered worse
than a mouse and keyboard
doesn't matter if they're on mobile we
have a guy in controller
but with a controller in hand and a
dream to dismantle every mouse and
keyboard player on the server
nick mercs destroyed the competition
with his signature run and gun playstyle
and after joining faze clan in 2019
nick merks found a platform where he
could give back even more
like the hundred thousand dollar
community barbecue he hosted
[Music]
[Applause]
but one can only drop into tilted towers
so many times before
getting well bored so nick mercs took
his talents to war zone call of duty's
newest battle royale
and he didn't miss a step yep
like fortnight years ago warzone
exploded on his channel
not only was he incredibly good at it he
genuinely enjoyed it
but all i'm telling you is when i close
my eyes at night all i see is this game
dying to get back on i wake up in the
morning i don't want to do nothing sort
of play
and in true nick mark's fashion the
michigan native once again decided to
give back to his community
this time by hosting a monthly warzone
tournament called the mfam
gauntlet the mfam gauntlet was a
spectacle for viewers and featured big
names from streaming and professional
sports
it also gave up and comers a chance to
compete via qualifiers the one player
from each of the winning teams each week
will move on to represent as a member of
the mfam team in the main event the main
event
is like uh like a keemstar
or like a code red it's gonna be an
invite only a lot of the big names
big content creators pro players these
guys are gonna be in this event
and if you guys do good in the mfam
gauntlets leading up to the
the big one you can get a chance to
participate in that big one needless to
say the tournament was a giant hit
pulling in hundreds of thousands of
viewers across multiple different
streams in fact it's gotten
so big that warzone's publisher
activision has partnered with nick mercs
to make the mfam gauntlet
even greater doubling the prize pool to
a hundred thousand dollars
it's big things man big big things we're
partnered up with activision now
um and they're giving us a lot of leeway
a lot a lot of help
um across the board so you guys are
going to see some big [ __ ] coming
on top of that during these new versions
of the mfam gauntlet nick merks is going
to be raising awareness for the call of
duty endowment fund
which is a charity that helps out
military veterans nick merks is a
juggernaut in the world of streaming and
he's backed by one of the biggest orgs
out there
but despite his success he's remained
genuine and authentic
never forgetting to give back to the
community he created
over a decade ago thanks for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages